it was to be a meeting of leaders in a
place celebrated for its history where
past Muslim rulers shaped the city to
create a Heavenly Retreat on Earth but
the issues at hand are Far Cry from
Paradise there was plenty to discuss
among the members of the European
political Community the ongoing war in
Ukraine and maintaining a broad
Coalition of support for ke the main
challenge is what we have that is to
save unity in Europe Europe and I'm
speaking not only about the countries in
EU in in all the Europe I think that is
the the biggest challenge what we'll
have because Russia will will Attack by
information disinformation by by fakes
and Etc it was a chance for leaders to
restate commitment to defending Ukraine
but that's by no means the only test
being faced the recent aeri takeover of
the caraba region prompting a mass
Exodus of ethnic
Armenians but as azan's president ilam
aliev canel his visit plans for a
broader peace treaty were also
postponed with renewed tensions between
Serbia and Kosovo resurfacing there were
little signs of a breakthrough as
kosovo's president vosa Osmani refused a
meeting with her Serbian counterpart
Alexander vuic the question many have
asked here is how much progress could
have been possible Thursday's Summit
wased have provided a way for leaders to
have informal meetings to discuss these
pressing issues but apparently not
enough political will to find a working
solution the issue overshadowing the
summit the ongoing wave of undocumented
migration as thousands of people
continue to land on the shores of
southern Europe the EU announced a deal
to regulate sudden mass influxes of
people with Italy's Prime Minister
georia Mone finally backing the deal
after a proposal to get more NGO vessels
to take part in rescues was
dropped but continued opposition by
Hungary and Poland to any coordinated
plan means that this issue is far from
solved and that Unity on any planned
migration policy overhaul has yet to be
achieved Sonia Gago Al jazer
Granada make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer